المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا التاخير في
امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو
وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر
جدد
هو مجرد تصريح من بين تصريحات اخرى لقائد
مجموعه فاجنر
الذي رفع رايه التمرد في وجه الكريم
بدات كما لو انها فقدت السيطره عليه وباتت
ترغب الان في كبح جماحها صحيفه
اكدت نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي ان بريكوجين
تحول الى رجل قوي قادر على الوقوف ضد
اعضاء الحكومه الروسيه ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه والمؤسسه الامنيه الرسميه وبحسب
الصحيفه فان مؤسسه فاجنر بدا يفقد ثقه
موسكو بعد تصاعد غضب النخبه السياسيه
والعسكريه الروسيه من تصريحاته وتصرفاته
وحسب مصادر الصحيفه دائما فان مسؤوليه
يرون في قائد فاجنر تهديدا كبيرا وقد
قرروا تضييق الخناق على مجموعته وفضلا عن
كل هذا فان كبار المسؤولين الروس منزعجون
من انشغال بريجوجين بالتصريحات المنتقده
بين انه لم يكمل مهمته بعد في بخموت عدم
رضا الكريملين على بريكوجين دفعه الى
توبيخه بطريقه غير مباشره اذ لم تتم دعوته
لحضور خطاب بوتين في الذكرى السنويه
الاولى لانطلاق العمليه العسكريه كما تم
منع ممثليه من دخول مقر القياده العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا في المقابل بدا
مستعدا للمواجهه مع الكريم حيث اشتكى
علانيه من عدم حصول قوته على الاسلحه
والذخيره وعدم السماح له بتجنيد عناصر
اضافيه لكن السؤال المطروح الان كيف
سيتعامل الرئيس الروسي مع هذه المواجهه
بين بريكوجين والكريملين فحسب مصادر صحيفه
اوروبيا قال ان بريكوجين سيظل في منصبه
طالما ان روسيا بحاجه اليها او بالاحرى
طالما ان المعارك بحاجه الى مقاتله وسام
الذهبي العربيه